ladies and gentlemen
all across the globe the label made in
europe
is a symbol for the top quality of your
products
and you
europe's entrepreneurs
you can be rightly proud of this
but
made in europe means so much more than
reliable products
made in europe means that a product
comes from a place where we protect the
environment
and where workers earn a decent wage
it means that it comes from a continent
that has embarked on the modernization
of its economy and society
towards a more sustainable way of living
and working
in building this new european growth
model
industry is our indispensable ally
and i'm delighted to share some thoughts
with you
at this year's industry days
on how industry and the european
commission can complement each other
to unlock our green and digital future
just two days ago we presented a crucial
piece of this agenda
and this is europe's first ever chips
act
semiconductors have become front page
news in these months
when the global chip shortage has slowed
down the global recovery
factories closed in east asia and entire
production lines here in the european
union came to a standstill
however europe's global semiconductors
market share is only 10
today
and most of our supplies come from a
handful of producers outside europe
i think we simply cannot afford this
dependency and uncertainty any longer
and this is why by 2030
20 of the world's microchips production
should be here in europe
that's twice as much as today in a
market
that is set to double in the next decade
so it means quadrupling today's european
production
allow me for a moment to reverse our
point of view
instead of focusing on what we do not
have
let me focus on europe's strength in the
field of semiconductors
europe is the world's center
for semiconductor research
and europe is strong in some specific
areas
such as chips for cars or for industry
4.0
their crucial niche where europe is a
global leader
but i want us to become
a strong player all across the chip's
value chain
the european chips act will back this
ambition with considerable investment
and this will come on top
of more than 30 billion euros of public
investment already for seen
backed by next generation eu
our recovery program
and by horizon europe
as well as national budgets
and to put numbers in perspective
european companies in the semiconductors
field are now investing roughly 6
billion euros per year
so the european chips act can be a game
changer
our work will focus in particular on
five areas first on research
we will invest in a field where we are
already punching above our weight
focusing for instance on transistors
below three nanometers
and on disruptive technologies on
artificial intelligence
thus on research europe can go from
strength to strength
the second point is from the lab
to the fab
we must translate our excellence and
research into industrial innovation
so we will invest in ships design and in
pilot lines for prototypes
thus bridging the gap between the
laboratory
and the actual manufacturing of the most
innovative chips
my third point
is on production capacity
europe needs new advanced production
facilities
these facilities come with huge upfront
costs and therefore
public support can be necessary to
attract private investment
and for this reason we are adapting our
state aid rules
of course under a set of strict
conditions
and this will allow
for the first time
public support
for european
first-of-a-kind production facilities
which of course benefit all of europe
my fourth point is
that it is not just about mega fabs
the european ships act will also support
smaller innovative companies in
accessing finally advanced skills and
industrial partners and
equity finance
and finally
it is of course on supply chains
get me right europe will always work to
keep global markets open and connected
but we need to tackle the bottlenecks
that slow down our own growth
and we can create more balanced
interdependencies
and build supply chains that we can
trust
we will work on semiconductor
partnerships with like-minded partners
from the united states for example to
japan
and this is in the world's interest and
of course it is also in our own interest
this is of course equally true with
respect to our green transition
europe is the most ambitious continent
in the world
when it comes to the path to a net zero
future
we want to be the first climate neutral
continent by 2050
and you know that for this
we will reduce co2 emissions by at least
55 by 2030.
here also
industry is our close partner
because europe's entrepreneurs seize the
opportunities of innovative and clean
technology much earlier than others
just look at the large number of patents
in the field of climate and energy
they are striking proof of this
pioneering role
europe is there to nurture and support
this commitment in the best possible way
and let me illustrate this with three
recent examples
firstly europe helps with ideas
look at this conference
its main topics are a case in point
in the last two days you have discussed
how the construction sector can overcome
shortages of wood and other materials
for example by recycling materials or
using them more efficiently
you spoke about how european car makers
will profit
from our european battery alliance
because sustainable batteries made in
europe
are long-awaited alternative to imports
from asia
and you discussed what europe can do
to support energy intensive industry
to overcome the recent price hike
actually a topic
i will shortly come back
to in a more detail
your discussions show
that the question is not anymore whether
europe should become carbon neutral by
2050.
the question is how to get there most
efficiently
of course the european union industry
days
are an excellent opportunity to drive
this debate forward
and i call on industry to bring in its
expertise even more
when we finalize the transition pathways
together
the road map for different industrial
domains
europe also supports industries
transition
with the level of investment never
before seen on this scale and this is my
second point
just look at next generation eu our 800
billion euro recovery program
with next generation eu
we are investing in our sustainable and
digital future
like never before
and
we're tackling the structural challenges
of our economies
be it electric cars
green
hydrogen or a european renovation wave
that will make our homes and offices
more climate friendly
and our heating cheaper
450 million europeans are demanding
these changes
and i do not have to tell you
how much europe's industry can profit
from that
europe will be at your side in turbulent
times and this is my final point
of course
i'm speaking about the current rise of
gas prices
europe imports 90 percent of its gas
and demand is rising across the world
first of all because of the global
recovery
but current geopolitical tensions of
course come at a price too
we import more than 40 percent of our
gas from russia
and apparently russia has no interest in
increasing supplies right now
despite peak prices
just look at gasprom its storage in
europe is nowhere near the level it
should be
and gas flows through the jamal pipeline
and ukraine remain low
all this shows that gas problem does not
behave like a regular gas supplier
corporate interests
and politics
seem to be closely intertwined
but the good news is that europe has
done its homework
since russia's occupation and annexation
of crimea in 2014.
today we have more than 20 large lng
facilities that european ports and gas
infrastructures
are deeply interconnected
this reduces our dependency on russian
gas and allows us to diversify our
supplies
we are actively engaging now with
partners like the united states norway
algeria azerbaijan qatar
the recent energy council with the
united states and my joint declaration
with president biden
are only the most recent signs for this
unprecedented cooperation
and we can do so much more
we can jointly procure gas to become a
more significant player on the
international markets
we can better use and expand our gas
storage facilities across europe
and we can build up strategic gas
reserves
like we have in place for oil
these and other measures the commission
will shortly propose to member states
alongside these measures however
the european green deal remains our most
effective insurance
against any future increase in
electricity and energy prices
for it is the co2 heavy old energies oil
coal and gas
that are becoming more and more
expensive
and it is our dependence on the import
that makes us so vulnerable to price
hikes
on the other hand the costs
for renewables
has been constantly falling over the
past 10 years
and every kilowatt hour of electricity
that europe generates from the sun wind
hydropower and biomass
makes us more independent from russian
gas and other energy imports
this is why we have to accelerate the
development and the deployment of
renewables everywhere in
europe and we will issue additional
recommendations to member states
on how to speed up approval processes
ladies and gentlemen
the right answer to the current price
increase is not less climate protection
or less ambition
the right answer is more and more
effective climate protection
and i know that i can count on industry
in this transition on your innovative
spirit
on your support for our european project
and on your proven dedication to
strengthen europe as the home of some of
the world's most innovative companies
the european commission stands ready to
support you on our common path
for a sustainable economy made in europe
thank you very much